lugar intenta reconstruir lo que hasta
hace unos meses fue su hogar el
sacrificio de toda una vida ahora está
hecho cenizas luego de que un misil
impactara en su lugar más preciado
yo estaba aquí cuando mi hijo murió en
la bomba
los cristales de la casa se rompieron y
el murió y
la reconstrucción de su casa llevará
meses incluso años más del 70% de las
casas aquí hemos un en el norte de kiev
están como esta completamente
destrozadas fueron bombardeadas durante
las primeras semanas en la batalla de
kiev y ahora mismo los ciudadanos están
intentando reconstruir sus hogares pero
están recibiendo muy poca ayuda
gubernamental sheriff es economista del
centro ucraniano de inversión estima que
el proceso de reconstrucción necesitará
ayuda económica internacional debido al
nivel de destrucción que sufre el país
44 millones de metros cuadrados de
viviendas fueron destrozados en ucrania
para reconstruir toda esta cantidad de
propiedades necesitaremos 36 mil
millones de dólares los trabajos se
están realizando ahora y los encargados
serán el gobierno ucraniano socios
internacionales y las naciones unidas
con la ayuda humanitaria
pero los subsidios tardan en llegar la
guerra continúa y dimitri a el tiempo
que le llevará a volver a tener un hogar
con 68 años y una pensión de 100 dólares
no es optimista
en su época
desde en el cómic
la reconstrucción en ucrania avanza
lentamente el peligro a una nueva
invasión frena las inversiones y deja a
cientos de ucranianos recogiendo los
escombros de sus casas bombardeadas